on m'a mis on m'a mis sur le papillon
mais mère de fanny trêve nerfs mais ça
m'a écouté on a décidé que j'étais
simplement mère de famille donc on va
jouer le rôle de la même soit fait quoi
sous en ce moment je travaille dans
l'immobilier à l'origine je suis
journaliste qui mène à tout comme on ne
sait pas exactement pas regardé voilà la
preuve ici pour vous souvenez il faut
fermer les écoles très beau oui tout à
fait pourquoi ce qui se passe c'est
assez à l'écouté je vais vous livrer
quelques témoignages que j'ai pu
recueillir auprès des copines
aujourd'hui oui j'espère qu'elles sont
devant leur poste parce que j'ai promis
de ramener leurs paroles jusque chez
vous d'accord alors on à valérie qui est
enseignante dans un lycée en seine et
marne ce sont les élèves qui nous
apprennent les cas positifs au niveau de
l'administration c'est le silence
puisque nous sommes en principe protégés
par les masques sauf que c'est
l'hécatombe dans le corps enseignant
beaucoup de collègues sont absents plus
aucune possibilité de remplacement
idem au sein de l'administration par
exemple dans mon lycée une secrétaire
positive a contaminé six de ses
collègues
pire encore les agents d'entretien sont
aussi touchés et là gros problème les
effectifs déjà restreint sont encore
réduits par les arrêts maladie nous
avons donc un problème de désinfection
des classes et ma copine kim explique
aussi que les cours de ps vont reprendre
sans masque en milieu clos et quelle
bonne idée
alors on va avoir d'autres témoignages à
vous nous en direz renault quand vous
voyez voilà ce que dit soumia déjà jimmy
mohamed est ce que vous vous êtes pour
fermer les écoles ou non les sons les
ouverte puisque à chaque fois qu'on a
demandé quelque chose le gouvernement
n'a pas tenu compte donc si je dis qu'il
faut pas les fermiers vont peut être
finir par les fermes et vous c'est quoi
votre conviction je suis perturbée parce
que quand on parle d'école on oublie que
c'est un ensemble qui est très
hétérogène il faut qu on distingue deux
choses les enfants de plus de 10 ans
jusqu'à 18 ans et les moins de 10 ans je
suis rendu compte sur les quinze
derniers jours que l'incident c'est à
dire le nombre de cas qu'on va avoir
chez les 10 18 ans a doublé et que
finalement les enfants du primaire et de
la maternelle serait un peu plus
épargnées étant donné qu'on n'a pas su
mettre en place de vraies mesures de
protection à savoir des doublés des
classes permettre aux enfants de suivre
une scolarité plutôt normal puisque ce
qui revient en ce moment c'est que les
lycéens et les collégiens souffre de la
situation actuelle et ont beaucoup
souffert du premier confinement donc moi
je pense que étant donné que l'épidémie
n'est pas contre les chez les adultes et
bien forcément elle circule chez les
enfants donc il faut fermer les armes
donc il faut fermer les écoles et
malheureusement quand on va fermer les
magasins
si on laisse les enfants ou à l'école
ils vont se contaminer et vont
contaminer les parents la maison et
finalement on ne pourra pas contrôler
l'épidémie tant que l'épidémie ne sera
pas contrôlée dans les écoles et on va
devoir prendre des mesures
certainement plus difficile dans les
jours à venir